hey Peter Reuben from wired here at what
is essentially The Times Square of the
show floor this year at comic-con which
is the sony booth behind me they've got
Elysium coming next year they have
looper coming in September behind me I
don't know if you can see if they're in
frame but there is a signing from the
cast of community going on right now but
what we're really here for in the
foreground as you can see behind me this
lovely ride is from total recall which
is coming out august 3rd and this is
director Len Wiseman is retooling not of
the early 90s flick with Arnold
Schwarzenegger but the original philip k
dick story we can get it for you
wholesale and that is as you can see the
car that Colin Farrell will be in and
perhaps Kate Beckinsale will be in a
couple of great costumes behind me so
that's August third we're going to go
find more to talk to you about there's
going to be a press conference later
today I think we're going to get some
more footage and exclusives about Total
Recall but until then there's going to
be more news wire calm comic-con all
weekend long
you